Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Martin, where are we
sitting?
We're on a on the road. We're on the
road. So, our set is not our normal set.
We're here somewhere in a bush. Yes. In
a little cabin here. So, please, if the
shadows and the lights and everything is
not right, don't comment. Just enjoy
what's happening. Exactly. We've just
come from a camp meeting, an overseas
trip, and we haven't been home yet. So,
it's been a long road. Yeah. I've
managed to pick up a frog in my throat.
So, please excuse that, too. Yeah. And
so, don't ask me how I am.
That's why I'm not going to. Let me give
a good cough and tell you, don't ask me
how I am. So, hopefully that frog of
yours will behave itself. Yes. We'll
have to whip it into shape, put it into
warm water or something. Yeah. But one
of the reasons we have to probably uh
sit here is everybody is wanting to know
what's going on in the Catholic Church.
Yes, we have an interesting
topic because Pope Francis has just
died and that leaves a great opportunity
for change.
So before we talk about that, shall we
say a word of prayer? Yes. Will you do
that? I'll do that. Our heavenly father,
we thank you that we can do this even
while we are busy traveling. We ask that
you enlighten our minds and that you
guide us in this discussion and that
your name be holy. You be glorified in
Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. But this is a very fascinating
time. Yeah.
And even uh Cardinal Dolan implicated
that it was almost like a special moment
like a divine intervention for a time
such as this and that he couldn't have
choreographed it any
better. So that is a very strange thing
actually to say, isn't it? It is
especially from somebody that died in
and somebody Yeah. and somebody with the
stature that Pope Francis
had. And there are some very interesting
points that have been raised in the
media and those points are fascinating
to me. Uh this pope, he he was a
postvatican 2 pope, right? Oh yeah, very
much so. A very um staunch
uh advocate for Vatican 2. Post Vatican
2. And there were many many cardinals
and many theologians and many lay people
and many ministries that were certainly
not
happy with the deviations that the
church was taking particularly since
Pope Francis was vehemently against the
Latin mass. Yeah.
And he even forbade that the Latin mass
should be uh used at all unless there
were very stringent u reasons or
permissions given for it. Well, can you
just explain to us what is the Latin
mass? Well, as the name implies, it was
spoken in Latin. Mhm. And there are
certain traditions that are associated
with the Latin mass.
For example, the Latin mass was
traditionally spoken by the priest, not
facing the audience, but even facing the
east. Oh, okay.
Now, that's very interesting because uh
the Bible has a lot to say about facing
the east. Right?
And in Ezekiel, we have admonitions
against the Pharisees and the leaders in
the temple that used to worship towards
their east. the east with their backs to
the
temple and most churches are built in
that direction in any case facing the
east and that was a pagan sun worship
culture
so a lot of uh
paganism and
Christianity underwent
synratism and a lot of mingling took
place and it's fascinating that many of
the churches
are actually built on pagan sites
and are on those foundations of pagan
sites. Even the Vatican
itself and this worshiing towards the
east was the ancient tradition but it
was steeped in paganism. It was contrary
to what the scriptures said.
So the Latin mass was spoken in Latin.
Of course the people didn't understand
Latin.
So it added an air of and an ambiance of
mysticism. Okay. Yeah. To the procedure
and supremacy towards the priest because
nobody could understand him. Correct.
Now of course there was a lot of uh
argument about how the mass should be
shared with the congregation.
And originally, of course, it was the
mass in two
kinds. In other words, the congregation
shared in the wine and in the bread, but
then they changed it to one kind. So,
the congregation didn't get the wine
anymore, but only the
host. And the host itself was not bread
that was broken. It was a round
wafer and it was placed in a monstrance
which was sort of a half
moon and uh even when they when they
parade the host through the streets it's
also placed in a monstrance. Yeah. Now
that also comes from pagan origins
because the the sickle moon represented
the womb of semi
raamis and the birth of the sun god
within that uh birthing womb was
depicted. So it was an ancient culture
that was brought into into Christianity
and mingled as a synratistic form of
worship. Okay. So, Martin originally of
course it was simple unleven bread that
Jesus
used and he used unfermented wine.
Uh within the Catholic system later the
unfermented wine was also replaced with
fermented
wine. Now that biblically doesn't make
any sense either. Mhm. Because leven or
fermentation was a symbol of sin. Yeah.
So if the bread had to be unlevened,
then the wine had to be unfermented
because it was a symbol of sin and in
Christ there was no
sin. The other problem was that the
mass over time
uh was considered a reenactment a
precise
reenactment of what happened on the
cross. Okay. And the other problem was
that they then introduced the idea that
it was the actual
sacrifice. Therefore, the bread had to
be
transubstantiated into the actual body
of Christ.
So it wasn't merely a symbol bread. It
now became the actual body of Christ. So
when you parttook of it, you parttook of
the body of
Christ. And the mass was read on a very
regular basis daily and of course over
various congregations and districts and
time zones. It later turned out that
there is not a
second in the world when there isn't
some mass read somewhere. Sure. Which
means of course that the actual
sacrifice of Christ is
repeated every single second somewhere
on this earth. Yeah.
Now that's blasphemy.
Well Martin I think you are right
because the Bible says by one sacrifice
he has forever made perfect.
So Martin when we look at these things
we have to we have to see what is going
to happen to the Roman Catholic Church
now because since 196 since the 1960s
1962 Vatican
2 there has been this move to accept the
different
churches no longer as you know apostate
but as separated brethren.
and they were going to come back to the
church and that was the whole aim of the
ecumenical movement and the ecumenical
movement was not set up for
Catholics because they were the mother
church. Yeah. They had their own
movement that was to combine the
churches. But the ecumenical movement
was concentrated in
Protestantism to make them come to the
position where they would come back into
the
fold not necessarily accepting the
doctrines because they are
irreconcilable.
Yeah. You cannot reconcile Protestant
doctrine with Catholic doctrine. You
cannot reconcile them. And so over the
years, the popes have emphasized that we
must lay doctrine aside. Yeah. And Pope
Francis was very strong on setting
doctrine aside. Now, if you set doctrine
aside, then basically anything goes,
right? That's true. That's why he could
embrace even paganism. paganism,
patchamama worship, and there's a lot in
the media about that, of course, because
that's a form of idolatry, right? And
it's one of the gripes that the
conservative side of the Catholic Church
actually
has. Then, of course, you can embrace
other religions that do not see Christ
as the way, the truth, and the light.
And so, that opened the way to the
Abrahamic Accord. Mhm.
Because there are more than there's more
than one way according to Pope Francis
to approach God. Yeah. Now, is that
biblical Martin? No. No. Because the
Bible says there's only one way in which
to approach God. So, can can an
organization that is
Christian
theologically unite with an organization
that denies Christianity? There's no
way. If you go to the Bible, it says
that can two walk together unless they
agree. Okay, but this goes even further.
Goes much further back than this.
So if we want to see what is happening
now within the Roman Catholic Church,
then we have an amazing
opportunity to see the fulfillment of
prophecy
in and we did mention a little bit of
this when Pope Francis was so sick. Yes.
But now it's come to fruition. Yes. So
now, like you mentioned, there's a very
good opportunity to see this unfold. And
then of course there are those that held
to the view that Pope Francis would
definitely be the last pope. Now in one
of our previous what's prof we distance
ourselves from that because
prophecy as it is written historic
continuous doesn't doesn't emphasize the
individual unless it specifically
mentions the individual like the first
king of Greece for example that would be
Alexander the Great. But it's the
principles that are mentioned in the
Bible. So we have to look at this from
the very historic roots of what is going
on and why
Catholicism started to become the the
most
powerful Christian movement. let's say
Christian inadverted commas and sort of
overran all the others and then the
Protestant
Reformation gave it a setback right and
set the record
straight and now the Protestant
Reformation seems to be over. So what
has achieved that and why? Well, people
say Rome has changed. Yeah.
But Rome might change in its attitude.
Yeah. Or appear to a change in its
attitude. But if Rome hasn't changed in
its doctrine, then Rome hasn't changed.
The rest is a facade. Yeah.
So Martin, the Bible
says that one of the key issues of the
last days is deception.
Jesus said, "Be careful that no one
deceives you." Yeah. Now, we spoke about
deception at the camp meeting now just
recently. And basically, what is the
purpose of deception?
The purpose of deception is to make you
believe something that is not true.
That's it. That's the purpose of
deception.
Now, does this necessarily mean that the
people practicing the
deception are deceivers?
No, they can be deceived themselves.
Exactly. So, well, by definition, if
they're practicing deception, they're
deceivers, but they can be unknowing
deceivers
because they've actually swallowed
whatever they believe is true, which
happens to be a deception. Yeah.
Okay. Now, the Bible also says that the
devil has gone into how much of the
world? All All the world. The whole
world to deceive it.
That means Martin that the whole world
is lying in deception. Yeah.
Now, that's a very serious issue. So,
how do we know who's deceiving who?
There's only one truth. Truth. And where
do we find that truth? in the Bible. Can
you find it in tradition? No. All right.
But the Roman Catholic Church says that
tradition is the framework in which it
identifies truth. Yeah. And the Roman
Catholic Church
also doesn't base its morality on the
Bible. No. It bases it on natural law.
Yeah. Now, natural law is what society
naturally does.
It's like it's acceptable. Yes. What's
normally accepted in a society that's
natural law. Uh because by nature they
are doing it. At the camp meeting I also
did an example and said like natural law
if you are on a cannibalistic island the
natural law is that it's okay to be a
cannibal. Yes. until something else
happens and it becomes part of a greater
society that doesn't have that. Yeah. So
basically natural law is based on
whatever norms are considered acceptable
in society.
Do we have a fallen nature? Yes. And the
heart is how wicked?
Desperately desperately wicked. So would
you like to base your morality on a
desperately wicked heart? No, definitely
not. And that's the one that Hollywood
continues to tell you to follow. Okay.
So what if you lived in a city like
Sodom?
Would natural law proclaim the
activities of that particular city as
acceptable? Yes.
Okay. And the scriptures base morality
on a higher standard, a divine standard,
not dictated by man, but dictated by God
and written with the finger of God in
stone.
Now when we use the terminology, it is
written in stone
then it's immovable. Yeah. Unchangeable.
Unchangeable. It's like the law of the
Mes and Persians, right?
Soon when we discuss what is happening
in the Vatican now, we actually should
go way back into history
and then we'll talk a little bit about
Pope Francis and what are the
possibilities in the future, right?
Yeah. Well, number one, how did
Catholicism
uh come
about and how did it gain ascendancy?
Well, if you go back into
history, the early
church consisted of the disciples. Yeah.
And those that joined themselves to the
disciples, right? And this church
flourished mainly in the east.
Mhm. So the seat of Christianity was at
Antioch and then as it spread it also
spread to other regions and then also to
Rome. Now it's interesting that uh the
Roman Catholic Church was just a church
in Rome. Uhhuh. And the Roman Emperor
still ruled from Rome.
And the Jews were constantly at war, the
Zealots, with the
Romans. And the Romans eventually got
fed
up. And
so they besieged Jerusalem. Mhm. And in
the year 70 AD, Jerusalem was destroyed
by Titus. Right. Yeah.
And the interesting thing
is the Jews didn't then cease their
operations because their hope was that
the kingdom would be given to them. They
misapplied the
promises and what they
considered the second
coming was what they appropriated them
to themselves where they would be
received the kingdom, an earthly one.
And they totally negated the first
coming which was to set up the kingdom
of accepting
Christ and turning away from
transgression. So that was not part of
their program. Even some of the
disciples had this mindset. That's it.
Up until that's why they were
disappointed. Correct. Because Jesus was
crucified. Yes. And one of them was even
a zealot. In other words, one that was
really determined to wipe the Romans
out. Right?
In any case, they didn't stop their
attacks almost like terrorist attacks
against Roman legions or soldiers and
they would constantly harass the Romans.
And in just after 150 AD, uh the emperor
that was ruling then was Hadrian.
And the emperor
Hadrean had it up to here. So there was
a second destruction of Jerusalem, even
more severe than the
first, and he totally
obliterated the Jewish state
and scattered the
nation and he forbade the Jewish
religion.
Okay? Amongst other things, he forbade
the keeping of the Sabbath. Now, this
put all of
Christianity into a spot.
because they had all been keeping
Sabbath until that time.
And it is well documented that the
church in the east kept the Sabbath and
in Africa they kept the Sabbath. And
even the Celtic church and the
Valdenzians and the Albagenzians, they
all kept the Sabbath, right?
So how were they going to get round this
impulse? How were they not going to be
associated with the Jews?
And the bishop of Rome came up with the
clever
idea that uh he could compromise on this
issue and say, "But we're not Jews
and we don't really have to keep the
Sabbath. We can keep the first day of
the week and celebrate it as the day of
the resurrection
and then we won't be associated with the
Jews." And that's basically where it
started. Okay.
So that's actually where Sunday keeping
really got. So the bishop of Rome is the
one that introduced Sunday keeping and
eventually he convinced some of the
compatriots in Alexandria to do the
same. So there were these two
conclaves that were Sunday keepers and
the rest of the Christian world were
Sabbathke keepers. And over centuries
there were many many wars and many uh
attempts to totally obliterate
Sabbathkeeping. But it always kept
popping up. Now that's the first thing
that
happened and that was a compromise with
the pagan world. Yes. Because they had
sun worship. Yes. So now if you had the
venerable day of the sun DS
solace then you were also able to draw
in paganism because the similarities
were there and and what if you mod what
if you
incorporated some of the ideologies of
paganism.
Now, one of the key features of every
single pagan culture in the world is
ancestor worship.
Right. Ex. Exactly. Yeah. Ancestor
worship. So
eventually in the Roman mill they
developed the
theology that the deceased
fathers got a special role. on the other
side. In order to do that, you have to
embrace the doctrine of immortality.
Yes. Okay. The first lie in any case.
All right. Now, the doctrine of
immortality is also part and parcel of
every pagan culture.
It forms the basis of pagan culture
because human beings eventually became
deified on the other side.
So now Rome didn't go so far as to deify
them but made them mediators
goetweens
between God and
man. The idea then started to
grow that in the pagan culture there
were
priests and the priests brought
sacrifices. Of course, within the Jewish
religion, there were also priests. Yes.
Right. They also brought
sacrifices. And the Bible tells us that
when Christ was sacrificed once and for
all, the priesthood, the sacrificial
system ceased to exist
because by one sacrifice he had forever
made perfect.
So the New Testament doesn't refer to
priests but refers to ministers. Yeah.
Now a minister is someone who ministers,
someone who is a shepherd. So now you
had now you had this
idea that the
minister worked with the congregation
and the priest that was worshiped was
the high priest Jesus Christ who had
taken the place of the levitical system.
Yeah. He had taken the priesthood under
the order of Malchisedc. Yes. Can you
just explain that portion?
uh that what would have happened if he
went into the temple? He would have been
killed when he was on earth. When he was
on earth because nobody was allowed to
enter the temple unless they were
Levites, right? They had to be the
descendants of Aaron and Jesus was a
Judeian. Yeah.
Now, as a Judeian, he couldn't officiate
within the temple. So his earthly
service was in the outer
courts and he became the sacrifice and
then he became a high priest of a temple
not built by human hands which is what
Hebrews says and there is only one
priest and only one mediator and that is
the man Christ Jesus. But in paganism
the priesthood was very important. They
also brought
sacrifices. So the papacy adopted a
priesthood. Now
Martin that means that there are no min
not ministers but officiating priests
that bring a
sacrifice. But now what was the
sacrifice? Yeah. There was no sacrifice
of sheep and goats because the Bible
says he entered not with the sacrifice
of sheep and goats but with his own
blood. Jesus entered into the holy.
Right.
So the philosophy and the theology
developed that the host of the last
supper was the sacrifice. But as a
priest it has to be a real sacrifice. It
has to be an enactment of what went
before. And this was where the doctrine
of
transsubstantiation
developed that the bread became the
literal body of Christ and the wine the
literal blood of Christ. That's almost
well to put it very blunt. Yeah. It's
like cannibalism.
Yes. Quite right. And of course then a
problem arises that if you hand out the
chalice of somebody to somebody and it
passes through the congregation like it
was in the beginning then what if
somebody spilt it?
That would be a disaster right? Because
now you spilled the literal blood of
Christ. And so it was decided not to
give the congregation the wine but only
the priest would partake of it. then you
could control the situation. So this is
how this developed over time.
Now the dead the ancestors were already
interceding on behalf yeah of
humanity and then of course they had the
doctrine of marology
and the papacy developed this doctrine
of marology. Now the Bible tells us that
Mary, the mother of Jesus, was born
under the law. Mhm. Right. That Yeah.
She was born under the law. That means
she was born under the condemnation of
the law. And that means that she
required redemption just like everyone
else.
Now, Rome developed the theology that
God is so holy, Jesus is so holy, he
couldn't have come into a vessel that
had a fallen nature.
That's just not conceivable in in that
kind of
thinking. And so they came up with the
idea that Mary by some miraculous decree
must have been declared immaculate.
Okay. Now, some of these doctrines,
Martin, only become
doctrine. Well, they were always
doctrine. They were always taught, but
they were never uh declared
infallible. Some of these only happened
in the last century or two. So, the
doctrines have been developing over
time, right?
So, Mary was declared immaculate by
decree of
God so that she could give birth to
Christ. Okay?
Now because of this he was above
humanity.
He didn't come all the way down to
humanity. So he didn't become exactly
the same flesh as we were. And the Bible
says that if you deny that he came in
the flesh that we are then you are
antichrist.
This is a bit of a serious accusation.
Right. Yeah.
And so this doctrine developed and Mary
was now immaculate. But imagine this,
Martin. If God could declare Mary
immaculate by a decree without sin,
Yeah. then couldn't he do it for you and
for me too? For sure. Then Christ didn't
have to die. He wouldn't have had to die
because then we would have been declared
sinless, right?
So the whole question of the atonement
is now highly problematic.
So they developed a
theology that Christ actually didn't die
for you.
He came to set the perfect obedient
example. His works were
perfect. And these perfect works were
the offset for the sinfulness of man. So
God was prepared to accept man on the
basis of the obedience of Christ unto
death. Uhhuh. But he didn't really shed
his blood for you. So in Catholic
doctrine, you still have to pay the
price. Now we've said this many times,
but we need to understand it in order to
understand the seriousness of the issue
and where it's where it originates.
probably also hitting correct. So Martin
what
happened is that the the Roman Catholic
system accepted the pagan doctrine of
purggation
purgatory where your sins that are
forgiven are paid
for. So in other words, Martin, if you
have been a sinner, then you have to
confess your sins. But you can't confess
them to God because he's way up there.
You need something in between in order
to do that. And this is where the priest
comes in. Yeah. And where the ancestors
come in, they take the place of Christ.
They take the place of Christ. They
become uh intercessors. And in the case
of Mary, it becomes so supreme that they
call them co-redeemers, co-redemptrices.
Okay? So you cannot talk or go to Jesus
directly. You have to go through one of
these. In in Roman Catholic thinking,
the sinner that ventures directly to
Christ does so with fear and
apprehension. So he employs the
mediation of the
mother and she presents it to the son.
Now what do they do with everybody
that's laid um burdened and laid and can
come to Christ? No, you have to go and
confess to a priest. So the decision of
the priest to pardon or not to pardon
takes precedence
and according to Catholic theology, God
has to subscribe to it. So the priest
now becomes on earth higher in position.
Yeah. Than Christ himself.
So this doctrine started
developing. Now there was a bit of a a
shift in the thinking of purggation. So
you were a sinner and you acknowledged
your sin. You went to a priest and you
confessed your sins and the priest gave
you a penance.
In other words, something that you had
to do to reciprocate. You had to pay for
it.
Now once you start paying for something,
Martin, it's no longer a free gift,
right? So you had to you had to do
something in
return. And then when you died, you went
to purgatory. Your sin was forgiven, but
it hadn't been paid for in full. So you
had to burn it off in
purgatory. And in Catholic theology,
that process can take a very, very long
time.
And the theology grew to such a point
where people were terrified of purgatory
because they were going to spend maybe a
millennium in purgatory on the basis of
a short life here on earth.
And how did this work? Well, they paid
for their own sin now with money. Not
yet. Oh, this is in this is now in
purgatory. So, this is paying through
pain. Paying through pain. Yes.
Now, how do you get an early release out
of that pain? That's where you have to
this is now where it gets
interesting. So, they developed a
theology of a treasury of merit. Now,
we've explained this before and I want
to tell you now, Martin, that the poor
Roman Catholic sitting in the pew,
doesn't it? Has no idea how this works.
They believe that Jesus paid the price.
They believe they can pray to Mary and
she will intercede.
But they believe that Christ paid the
price. Now p Christ paid the ultimate
price by giving up his life but not for
you just to the point of total obedience
unto death.
So now the question was how do we give
relief to these people and the theology
developed the theology which is called
the treasury of merit.
In order to get to heaven you have to
have certain meritorial points.
Can I put it that way? Yeah. This is now
trying to simplify the doctrine.
This merit determines how long you will
be in purgatory.
Now the doctrine developed that the pope
has access to a treasury of merit. So
these saints did more than was necessary
to merit heaven. So there was additional
merit and that went into this treasure
chest. And of course Jesus's meritorious
works are unlimited. They also went into
the treasure
chest. And the merit of Mary was
according to their doctrine supreme and
went into the treasure chest. So he has
basically an unlimited
bucket treasure chest of merit. Yeah.
And he could apply this merit to someone
who lacked merit
on the other side. Yeah. In purgatory.
This person is now deceased. Yes. And in
in purgatory, suffering excruciating
pain.
And the pope has now the power to
alleviate that pain by attributing some
of this merit to him.
That means he can get out of purgatory
sooner than normal. Okay. So, purgatory
is like a mini hell. It's a mini hell.
It's an in between hell. Of course, if
you never confessed your sins to the
priest, and you committed what they
called mortal sins because they
developed categories of sins, then you
went straight to hell.
Then you didn't go to that process at
all. So this is for confessed sins,
right? So the priesthood became
absolutely necessary for salvation.
Without priest you had no access to
heaven and the whole of the society was
hooked into this
system. Eventually it became uh a point
to ponder that this merit obviously had
value right. Yeah of course because it
could alleviate a lot of pain.
So what about selling the
merit? And that is what they started to
do. They started to sell the merit. That
was called an
indulgence. Now in the middle ages, they
were selling the merit for money. Yeah.
And you had Tesla going around and all
of these things and the world was in
total darkness. M now the first point
that you must
understand that everybody must
understand is that this system is no
longer Bible-based nor is it Christian.
No a long time well from everything
we've spoken now it's nothing based on
the Bible. There's nothing because you
are
now dependent upon the system the priest
in order to have your sins
forgiven. You're dependent upon the
pope. Mhm. in order to have merit
attributed to
you and you are paying the price for
everything that you did. Even though
your sin has been forgiven,
you are still going to pay the price. So
who becomes the sinbearer? You do.
So Christ is completely taken out of the
equation. We have a total pagan system.
It's not Christianity.
It invokes the name of
Christ and it says that Christ made it
possible for you to have eternal life
only because his merit was so great and
his deeds were so
wonderful that God because of the
greatness of his acts decided to forgive
humanity once they had paid for their
sins.
Do you understand what this is going?
It's a totally it's 100% the opposite of
what it is. It's not a Christian
doctrine. It's a pagan doctrine. That's
that's why it's not a Christian church.
Correct. And what happened, Martin, is
that the world plummeted into darkness.
Yeah.
Now, darkness is the absence of light.
Now, Martin, the other sad point
is that the people who were largely
illiterate
had no means of verifying this system.
They just believed it.
And then Rome still buried the
scriptures in Latin
that nobody
spoke. And so it was a very mystical
religion and
ceremony and pomp
and
glory took the place of substance and
people were actually ruled by fear. They
were ruled by fear. Then came the
reformation. And it was started because
of indulgences. Yeah. Martin Luther
recognized that
indulgences didn't make
sense. And he'd been studying the Bible
in Latin in his monastery. And it's
interesting that Yan Hus 100 years
before him had already recognized that
indulgences were not from God that they
were a means of simmon selling peddling
the gospel of
Christ. So when the reformation came and
they discovered the word again and
Martin Luther translated the Bible into
the vernacular tongue and Tindle did the
same for the English language and now
the Bible was available and people could
read from themselves. Then all these
papal doctrines based on tradition and
paganism and Greek
philosophy just dissipated. They were
swept
away and Christ was put back into the
center.
Salvation was through the blood of the
lamb. Christ paid the
price. The wroth that should have hit
man came upon Christ and he took upon it
himself willingly. So many Catholic
theologians would say well in that case
you must hate the father and love the
son. But it was a joint decision. They
would take the price, pay the price and
Christ would become sin for us. That's
why Moses had to lift up the serpent.
Not because the serpent is your savior,
but because Christ became sin for us and
paid the price. And without the shedding
of blood, there is no forgiveness of
sins. And when that curtain tore, you
had direct access to the throne. There
was no more priesthood. It ended. You
now had ministers.
And they were on the same level as the
congregation. Nobody was higher. It was
just a hierarchy.
But it wasn't a lordship. You shall not
lord it over each other, said Jesus. So
it's a totally different
system. And the Protestant
Reformation gradually understood. But
hold on, then there can be no mass.
We have to go back to the communion
because there can be no
transsubstantiation because that would
be an actual sacrifice requiring a
priest and requiring an altar. So
Protestantism threw all the altars
out of the
churches and they had the normal
symbolic message of the Lord's supper
commemorating a an act of God that had
already been done. Are you with me? Yes.
Okay. That started a war. Yeah. Christ
was back in the middle. There was no
such thing as a mass. There was no such
thing as ancestor worship. There was no
saint in heaven as mediator. Mary could
never be a mediator because there is one
mediator between man and God, the man
Christ Jesus. So those were vast
doctrinal differences that couldn't be
bridged. How were they bridged?
Well, Rome raised up other powers, the
Jesuits amongst others, and the idea was
to create a counterreformation.
So they used the theater. Yeah.
and Jesuit theater became the norm in
which they brought in paganism and
mingled it with with other ideas and
started to take over the education and
eventually they got so far in England as
to introduce at Oxford University the
Oxford movement and everything that had
been thrown out the altars and the
images they slowly came back because
humanity wants to see something. Yeah.
Wants to touch something, wants to be
able to confess to someone, then they
feel better. Whereas with Jesus, you
have to do it by faith. And that's not
they don't want that. They don't want
that. And the whole doctrine of
justification, how are you justified?
You are justified by faith alone in the
atoning blood of
Christ. So the dark ages were
dissipated.
Christ's light came into the world and
the world
blossomed. Then came the Oxford
movement. Then came the ecumenical
movement. And over centuries biting its
time, Rome chipped away, chipped away,
chipped away at Protestantism. Also
under a guise under a guise. Eventually,
I believe Martin that they not only
fermented but were actually behind the
complete liberal liberalization of
humanity and the total disregard for any
law divine or human
resulting in chaos that humanity cannot
bear. No, they they they actually they
the instigators of this whole thing. So
they themselves swung the pendulum. Yes.
To absolute do what thou wilt is the
whole of the law. That was in the French
Revolution. And then they allowed the
governments to have this liberal nobody
is in control
attitude and humanity started to become
degraded and we are now at the point
Mhm. where the pendulum must swing back.
So now let me read you something out of
the spirit of prophecy and then we'll
come to Pope Francis. Okay. Just want to
mention we mentioned this
pendulum probably since the beginning.
Yes. Correct. And then it's already
swung in the political sphere.
Correct. Now let me read something to
you. Foremost, this comes out of the
great controversy. Foremost amongst
those who were called to lead the church
from the darkness of popery into the
light of a purer
faith stood Martin Luther, zealous,
ardented and devoted, knowing no fear
but the fear of God and acknowledging no
foundation for religious faith but the
holy scriptures. Luther was the man for
his time. Through him, God accomplished
a great work for the reformation of the
church and the enlightenment of the
world. Yeah.
Now, let's
continue. So, this pagan
system was swept away in large areas of
the world by Protestantism.
The BBC clung to some areas and even by
military means maintained them. But then
it used other methods to slowly erode
Protestantism.
Here's another quote, Martin, and it is
a quite a long one, but I'm going to
read it. The accession of the Roman
church to power marked the beginning of
the dark ages. Uhhuh.
As her power increased, the darkness
deepened. Faith was transferred from
Christ, the true foundation, to the Pope
of Rome. He had access to the treasury
of
merit. Instead of trusting in the son of
god for forgiveness of sins and for
eternal salvation, the people looked to
the pope and to the priests and pates to
whom he delegated authority.
They were taught that the pope was their
earthly mediator and that none could
approach God except through
him and further that he stood in the
place of God to them and was therefore
to be implicitly obeyed like a god.
Yeah. A deviation from his requirements
was sufficient cause for the severest
punishment to be visited upon the bodies
and souls of the offenders.
Thus the minds of the people were turned
away from God to fallible, ingring and
cruel men, name more, to the prince of
darkness himself, who exercised his
power through them. Sin was disguised in
a garb of sanctity. When the scriptures
are suppressed, and man comes to regard
himself as supreme, we look only for
fraud, deception, and debasing
iniquity. With the elevation of human
laws and traditions was manifest the
corruption that ever results from
setting aside the law of God. So they
had a new system of morality. God's law
was gone. The Sabbath was replaced with
Sunday worship because it was dear
solace the venerable day of the sun. The
churches faced the east and the priest
faced the east when he brought his
sacriigious sacrifice repeating what
Christ had done once and for all. And
they also say that the salvation is in
the church. So in the system without the
Catholic church there's no salvation
unless it is transferred from their
authority to others. Now but what is
interesting is that deception has a aim.
Mhm. Now, what is the deeper aim of
deception? The deeper aim was to rob
Christ of his heritage. Yeah. Because if
you can take away the plan of salvation
and substitute it for something else,
then you have robbed Christ of his
heritage because the road leads nowhere.
Yeah. Nobody comes to the father except
by me. And he was a total new system.
Yeah.
Now, who would have ever thought that an
age of darkness with such dark doctrines
could ever again be accepted by the
world? Surely the darkness should have
been swept away forever. Well, does the
Roman Catholic system church see those
those years or that those centuries as
dark? No, they see them as light. And we
will see that in a moment.
Here's another quote from Great
Controversy, page 572, paragraph 3. A
day of great intellectual
darkness has been shown to be favorable
to the success of the papacy.
It will yet be demonstrated that a day
of great intellectual light is equally
favorable for its
success. Now, I want to start there.
Yeah.
Under Pope Francis, you had a
pope who was the ultra liberal.
You can call him a woke pope. Yep.
And the media and the conservatives were
highly upset with some of his
activities, particularly basically
banning the Latin mass except for some
orders that were particularly entrenched
in that particular
activity. and then his wokeness, his
stance on male and female, the LGBT
community, abortion, all of these
issues, all of them. And he permitted
even pro-abortion presidents to take
part in the mass,
which is a sacriigious sacrifice in any
case. And Martin, this
wokeness was the the heyday, the
highlight of liberalization, right? Yes,
it was. It was the pinnacle. They so
long strife for this period where this
would reign supreme and it became like
that. And it came to the point where
people saw no point in Christianity
because it had become toothless. Yeah.
allowing everything even though it was
deported. Right. And so people were
leaving the churches in droves. The
churches were empty. Yeah. And some of
them became pubs and some of this became
that. But some of them are beautifully
maintained. They're ready for something.
And some of them have gone great
renovations in the last because they
burnt down. Yes. and they will be
reignited as it were because the papacy
wants to lead people back to what they
call light. Yeah. The dark ages. That's
it. If you compare it to Bible do the
Bible doctrine and light. It's total
darkness. That's why we mentioned total
darkness. So here you had uh Benedict
who was a conservative.
Another word just sorry for interrupting
but another word is traditional. Yes.
Nothing but tradition, nothing based on
the Bible. And then you had his
replacement while he was still alive,
Pope Francis. And you had the super
liberal
agenda. And all the super liberals loved
him. He was their hero. And the
conservatives became more and more
disenfranchised. They were very unhappy.
Now if you take what's happening in the
United States at the moment is the swing
towards liberal Catholicism or is the
swing towards conservative the well we
we've spoken about just the cabinet and
the people of Trump and the people in
there it's all conservative traditional
Catholic highly Catholic highly
traditional prevatican 2 theology. So
now we've had a postvatican 2 theology.
If we can take humanity back to a
prevatican 2 theology, then the papathy
will have been fully restored to what it
was in the middle ages. Exactly.
Wouldn't the wound be healed? Then it
would be healed. Now what if church and
state then came back and simultaneously
embraced the philosophy and the mock of
its authority and introduced it to
society. Wouldn't that be amazing? It
would. And people will accept in in the
majority accept this correct because
they're so fed up with other portion of
wokeness. Now let's just have a look at
some
things. Pope Francis left a will. Yes. A
testament. Yeah. Where he explained that
he wanted to have a very simple burial.
Mhm. But who did he commit himself to?
Who did he commit his soul to? To Mary.
To
Mary. Now, Martin, who's the one who
will resurrect you? It's Jesus Christ,
right? Yes.
And he's the one that you're supposed to
have your faith in. And without faith,
it is impossible to please God, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So, here we have an
alternative. Now if Mary is a
co-redemptric as Rome claims and a
co-mediator then that negates the Bible
that says there's only one mediator
between man and and God and only one
advocate right. So this is a pagan
structure. So in a sense if it doesn't
stand for Jesus then it must stand for
an adversary. Yeah. Somebody who takes
the place of antichrist. Antichrist.
It's a whole Antichrist system.
If you throw in a couple of saints to
make it less
harsh, then that is something that
people would like to understand, right?
And then the Bible still forbids uh
repetitive prayer. But what is the
rosary other than repetitive prayer? And
in the rosary, there are 10 Hail Marys
to one our father. Yeah. So, so who has
preceded? Mary. Now, Pope Francis
committed himself to Mary just as Pope
John Paul II did as well. So, they
committed themselves to Mary. So, it is
an antichrist
system. And Martin, what is happening in
the United States and the cabinet?
Didn't they have a meeting recently
where the Catholics parttook? That's it.
And at Mara Lago, Mara Lago, that's what
happened there. There was a big meeting
Catholics for Catholics and it was all
traditional prevatican 2 Catholics
conservative ones everybody that you
that is anybody in that vicinity um had
were there and had speeches. Yes. And
it's
interesting that over the Easter weekend
Mhm. There was this meeting where Christ
was again emphasized and the the
Franklin
Graham was over the moon about the
transision that had taken place.
Exactly. The previous year you had a it
was dedicated to transgenderism or
something. Correct. Now what's more
fascinating it's not only the
cabinet that has moved towards
traditional Catholicism displaying it
openly in Ash Wednesday celebrations etc
with a vice president receiving the mark
etc and Protestantism doesn't say a word
nothing Protestantism doesn't exist
anymore it actually applauds it yes it
applauds it so Martin have they moved
back to traditional Catholicism. Yes.
And they long for it. They don't even
have a whimper. So, can they be
Protestants? Are they protesting the
doctrines of Rome? No. No. They're
looking at the soup kitchens. They're
looking at the revival. Are they looking
at the revival of morality? They're all
very excited, but they don't know what
that morality is based on. Natural law
and where it's heading. And where it's
heading. And so Martin, you have all of
a sudden whereas in the last few years
you had a massive decline,
you have a massive resurgence of
Catholicism. It took only a few months.
And what did they use? Didn't they use
the celebrities? They all turned to
Catholicism
one after. And what's happening with the
youth now? Well, where it used to, like
you just said, churches were running
empty. You got an influx and they can't
even keep up in Cathol Catholicism. And
where's it going? Is it going towards
Protestantism or is it going to
Catholicism? Catholicism. And the
interesting part is they want
conservative tradition to come back. All
right. So the youth wants conservative
traditional
Catholicism. The man standing in the way
of that was Pope Francis. Yeah. Right.
Mhm. And I don't know whether anybody
watched the movie The
Conclave where they discussed the
election of the next pope as it were and
they said they can't go back to the
ancient things. So they basically
uh took a hermaphrodite bisexual and he
became pope showing that the the modern
papacy would be all inclusive and that
wokeness and all of these ideologies
would not go. But
Martin there are priests and pre-lates
who are saying we have to go back to the
ancient traditions. Yeah. And they are
saying we have to go back to the light.
Yes.
They're calling it light. They're
calling it light. But history calls it
the dark ages.
But this is to me very fascinating
because if they manage to do that, if
they manage to go back to what they call
light, then they are literally saying
that the darkness of the middle ages was
light. Yeah. And what does the Bible say
about that? Woe to him. Woe to those who
call light darkness and darkness light.
And this is the ultimate betrayal of
Jesus Christ because then the whole
system will have been washed away. By
the way, did Pope Francis issue
indulgences? Yes. So, did he firmly
stand for indulgences? Oh, very much so.
It's the jubilee here. He opened the
door. All of this. So if Martin you had
indulgences,
then Christ is not a mediator that paid
the price for your sin
because there would be no need for an
indulgence. All it takes is to go onto
your knees and thank him for the
sacrifice, accept it by faith, and
appropriate to yourself. And as we have
said a thousand times, the worst sin in
my opinion that Protestantism has done
in the last
decades was to to compromise the
doctrine of justification. Wonder which
is the pillar of Protestantism. And that
joint declaration, I'm going to quote it
again, which says by grace alone through
Christ's saving work, we are justified.
Nope. That is diabolical. Yeah. Because
it is by faith alone in Christ's atoning
blood that we are justified.
Christ's saving works goes into the
treasury of merit. That's Catholic
doctrine. And it is by faith alone that
you are saved because without faith it
is impossible to save you. Yes, you
receive grace, but you have to
appropriate it by faith in the blood.
That's justification. So the compromise
is totally Catholic. Yeah. So they all
and just to put it bluntly, everybody
that signed that declaration is back
under Catholics and they say it's
supreme. And because the world is so
chaotic,
Protestantism is willing to go along
with it just to get some morality back
under the semblance of Christianity.
Now, there's a video out of what one
priest said in an interview. Can we play
that? Yes, let me play it. So, where do
you think things sit right now? I mean,
you see you see two camps kind of
emerging. I think I maybe explained both
sides of this social media saying, "Wow,
the the woke pope has has died. What
will the church look like going forward?
Will we have a return to traditional
traditional Catholic values?"
um or are we moving in a totally new
direction? Where do you see things going
for the Catholic Church worldwide?
If we look at the younger generation,
over this last couple of months, we've
had lots of data come out from different
organizations that shows that younger
people are seeking tradition. they are
finding the Catholic faith and this is
across the west particularly in America
and in my home country Great Britain
where we have the church of England
which has been the predominant uh
Christian denomination for the last 500
years and for the first time ever it
looks like Catholics are taking over so
we're seeing this across the board this
this finding of traditional worship and
traditional Christian values and so I'm
hoping that the next pontiff happens to
be a conservative traditional property
sound Catholic cuz that will be it was
it's just the perfect timing as young as
the next generation are looking for for
tradition and and and sound doctrine. If
if a pope stands up now that can embrace
them and embrace the tradition of the
church, it could be a good thing for the
world actually. If we see a return to
Christendom in the west, away from
liberalism and progressive secularism
and all the things that are tearing us
apart and introducing a death culture,
we could head back away from the light.
Sorry, away from the darkness, back
towards the light, which be would be a
wonderful thing to behold. Did you hear
that?
Going they want us to go back to the
dark ages, but they calling it light. So
basically what they're saying is that
Protestantism was never able to reign in
morality that they absolutely failed. It
is only Catholicism that can give you
the stability that is needed and we have
to go back to the light. And for the
first time Catholicism is outstripping
even the church of England is
outstripping Protestantism everywhere in
the world. and it will be enshrined.
I'm just thinking, you know, how clever
they were. They've made in the past few
months since Trump has come in
Catholicism that um attractive. Yes. And
then Dolan says this is providential. It
is the right timing. Right timing for
what? for Catholicism to take back the
scepter, to step back in history into
the dark ages and to be enshrined. And
who will enshrine her? Spiritism and
Protestantism will lift her up as the
standard. And the standard of God, the
ten commandments as they stand written
in stone will be lain in the dust. Ex.
And the problem is that Protestants will
are very pro this whole movement because
like you just mentioned it seems as if
this morality that's what they want to
follow but they don't they put the
doctrines aside. They're looking at a at
a religion of works and Christ is
negated and they they see no difference
between a Roman Catholic mass and a
Protestant communion service. It all has
blended because they have buried
doctrine, biblical
doctrine in order to achieve peace and
unity. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. and Martin.
This is the last straw. God gave
everybody the
opportunity to see what Catholicism was
about. It was an anti-Christian system
that used the name of Christ to negate
him.
That placed a system of earthly
mediation in the place of the great
mediator.
It was exposed in the
reformation. It was buried in the
counterreformation. It was made
toothless in the ecumenical
council. And now she's going back to
what she calls light, which the Bible
and even history called darkness.
I
expect that the pendulum will spin swing
to a conservative pope as that priest
iterated and I would be very surprised
if it doesn't happen. No, but we will
wait and see. We are not sages. We do
not know what is going to happen. But if
the Roman Catholic Church is going to
retake its position of the moral leader
of
humanity, then she has to take that
power that she had in the Middle Ages.
She has to take it back. And that would
be the total healing of the wound. And
if she can get the state Mhm. to support
her doctrines, they already do, then the
end will be there. They already do. I am
so glad that these things are happening
because I really want to go home. What
about you? Oh, for sure. Amen.
So, I don't want to say I'm glad that
Pope Francis is gone because that would
be mean, but I'm saying I'm glad that
the opportunity for the last events to
take place when mankind was warned in
such a powerful way to set a pagan
system aside and accept the true gospel
of salvation in Jesus Christ. To reject
it a second time, that's like the second
siege in Jerusalem. It's over.
Wow. Just on that one, Rome is
definitely coming. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we do not know what
will happen in the Vatican next, but we
do know what the Bible says that the
that the wound will be healed and that
she will take back that position which
she
lost. And Lord, when she takes it back
and the whole world is
deceived, then the answer will
be a time of trouble such as never was,
culminating in the plagues and the
second coming of Jesus to claim his
kingdom. Mankind will have had its
opportunity. They will have officially
rejected it and the consequences will be
dire. help us as individuals to make
decisions based on biblical principles
is my prayer in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. Heat. Heat.
[Music]